la machine a renvoyé un terminateur à l'
époque d'avant la guerre pour tuer ma mère
Sarah Connor m'a laissé la sauver initialement
son histoire nous savons que kyle est renvoyé pour
trouver Sarah Connor et lui sauver la vie
je vais revenir pour avoir peur et prendre faible
soin d'un [ __ ] de Kyle mais la beauté de
Terminator Genisys c'est que Kyle Reese
trouve une Sarah Connor très différente
dis moi si tu veux vivre
dal soldat Skynet a essayé de renvoyer quelqu'un
pour tuer les parents de Sarah bon tourne un
tour sur le modèle t 1000 liquide  le
changeur de forme en métal a juste besoin d'une touche
quelque chose d'Amérique c'est intéressant pour
Sarah parce qu'elle conserve les traits que
nous voyons dans Terminator 2 mais elle les a
découverts à un âge beaucoup plus jeune,
elle a été élevée par un terminateur donc
elle a grandi en tant que guerrière
vous